what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to an abba and preach
video pay for me because i look good
watch this backfire before i start do
not forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
all right let's get started um i have a
pretty simple one i just feel like men
don't get when
women put a lot of effort into their
appearance like we get our nails done we
get our hair done we pay a lot for an
outfit and all that
and then they don't want to like pay for
dates or like pay for anything and they
just expect us to look good all the time
i don't pay for outfits i don't pay for
shoes
i don't pay to go to the barber every
now and then i don't pay for cologne i
don't pay what makes you think i don't
pay you don't even value what's in front
of you lady me smell good you think i
don't have like shower
body body wash in my house all sorts of
different things come on
guys we don't have to
just common sense just using common
sense
it costs more for girls to be girls
probably not me because i'm very low
maintenance um but i probably could be a
little bit hotter if i like dyed my hair
invested in clothes
like there are things i could do i don't
right
but just common sense if a girl really
puts effort into her appearance
it definitely costs more to be a girl
than a guy
the shape of the dress shape up the
dress you think these just come like
that what about your outfit like what
you think
you think my fit this you think this
this is free my [ __ ]
huh
you think these are free my [ __ ]
look at that flick of that wrist
look at the flick of that wrist uh-huh
look at how flicking that wrist
the hell is this you think all this is
for free you did my fit
my fence for free
it's just laying there in my way you
think i don't pay for [ __ ] you feel it i
should show up butt naked is that what
it is i just show up in my joggers what
happened in the show if i don't show it
to if the gray joggers what happened you
know if it's gray joggers you're gonna
be like yeah okay but if it's a date
date like you're talking like you put
effort but because i don't put makeup on
i don't put effort on girl
the [ __ ]
you think oh
all this freshness so i can see both
sides the one thing i will say is i
don't think men are asking for women to
like put on a pound of makeup
do all like this crazy stuff um
but i agree that overall if you're a
girl that actually like
takes
i hate to say it but takes like good
care of herself like dresses nice all
that it definitely costs more it's gonna
cost you more than a guy it's the [ __ ]
you think this is why did you turn to
mary j blige what's that
spicy chicken
spicy chicken
[Music]
you think men should notice their nails
they do
oh you think men should notice your
nails your pedicure
your good looks and they like damn this
girl she put in work
and that's why i should pay
well yeah because we put in so much
financial effort into our appearance
so what if a dude comes in and he's
extra buff wears the nicest armani suit
perfume on point hair gelled up looking
mint as hell putting all the hours in
the gym got the best physique looking
like tyrese all right when he was still
doing r b okay are you paying for the
date
i'm never paying for the date
the [ __ ] i'd be here with your phone oh
i didn't want to do that
i'm gonna tell you why i wouldn't go on
a second date with a guy that asked to
split
um
and it's not for the reasons you think
i don't care if the date costs five
dollars i don't care if it costs ten
dollars i've always said like good date
for me is coffee chipotle
um you know just
short thing where i can get to know you
a little bit if it doesn't go well we
can bounce
like i don't want to be taken to like a
five-star restaurant if i don't know you
that well but
um the reason like i wouldn't go on a
second date with someone that didn't pay
it's because i don't want to be on a
date with the type of guy
that's gonna be like
so uptight about like paying on the
first date
um
it's just like
i don't know it's just some of the red
pill guys are so
annoying with that stuff like it could
be a ten dollar meal
and they're not generous enough on the
first date to pay for that um to me that
signals they're not very interested
i'm not saying he has to pay for like 10
dates i'm not saying it's got to be
super expensive but
personally like
i
i
know that if a victoria's secret model
walked in and asked for coffee he would
probably pay for her
um
so i'm not gonna
go on a second date with the guy that
doesn't pay oh my god i really
we have to make it equal let's make it
fair yeah is this your [ __ ] phone give
me your real phone you think i'm stupid
give me your real phone
no no yeah you take it give me your real
phone yeah we throwing this one here
let's go
you thought i could do that too
it's okay all right yeah i know i mean
laying on the bed first just don't just
the sun
out of compassion because i was nervous
for you it did land on the bridge
out of the way
no no when you threw it it found we both
got nervous
it's out of respect though i want to do
that i actually want an iphone so i can
go on instagram
you're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] get my phone
[Laughter]
she said no she said no i'm not paying
for never i'm never paying nothing to do
with the price that's what i said
there's nothing to do with price [ __ ]
out of here you just don't want to pay
[ __ ] out of here take all your nice [ __ ]
your clothes your your hair your nails
your fit your shoes your purse
get the [ __ ] out of here it ain't got
nothing to do with that ain't got
nothing to do with the price
to me it's just like you want to date a
guy that's chivalrous and generous i'm
not saying it has to be like the same
type of chivalry from the 1950s but do i
want to date a guy that's going to sweat
over a 10 chipotle meal
no sorry don't want to pay i don't want
i showed up
i shut up
i'm here i showed up so you should pay
that's what the [ __ ] it is
knobby do that again
that's a good character
that's good that's good but that's what
it is though yeah if i was at the
olympics i raised the 10.
i shut up
i [ __ ] my own routine but ash salute
to the judges fell in
salute ass showdown
today's video is sponsored by surf shark
feed people that you're interacting with
and so if you're trying to view online
if you just had simple clean nails
simple clean you know feet okay if you
had minimal makeup and you had like a
decent outfit
do you think men would be like
i'm not going on a date with this girl
no but i'm talking about no but i want
to ask her do you think those men would
not go on a date with you no they would
still
go on a date but
we were already in just because you came
on with extra add-ons that i didn't ask
for did men ask you to do a pedicure
i have men say that they appreciate when
women do pedicures and happiness i
appreciate a lot of things i think it's
great when you wanted to wear a nice
alpha did men ask for that
no
do we require it
some men say they prefer it hey i prefer
a lot of things i go to work some days
and i prefer having like a a luxury
chair when i'm doing my office work
but if you said hey you want that office
chair it's going to cost you more money
i'd be like put it back this give me the
regular
i didn't ask him if you give it to him
oh my god he's [ __ ] thank you but i'm
not gonna pay more i don't understand
why ladies put all this extra stuff that
we never asked for we never uh tell me
one girl
or one guy
who messaged you and said hey
make sure your nails done your your your
nails your [ __ ] feet done all right
put on extra makeup we're the nicest
when does a man ever ask you okay let me
let me not answer your question and and
go back to the other [ __ ] i was talking
about i'll let you know this i've
learned from that mistake i don't let
them run away [ __ ] i ask you a question
no no
answer my question answer that question
let's see what her answer is when does a
man ask you that
i've had a man say that he likes me
better when i'm dressed up and i have my
nails done all that but that's not what
i asked you it's not what i asked you
when does a man ask you to do that or
made it a requirement
never
so there you go first boss
he's my thing
you look good congratulations
so are they saying that men shouldn't
pay for the first date at all like it
should be 50 50 throughout the whole
relationship i'd be curious
you look fresh congratulations
you expect me to play you played
yourself
okay
i didn't ask for all that
if i show up to a date and i got a ten
thousand dollar armani suit
am i expecting you to pay because i put
in all this effort i put in all this
financial burden of course not her logic
nonsense okay guys come on
you know in general it costs women
more
to look good than it does men and in
general
women are judged harsher by their
physical appearance we we know this we
don't have to like
go to the extreme how many guys do you
know that wear our armani suits
um no i don't even really disagree with
her i just wouldn't want to date a guy
that's fretting
over like the 10
15 it costs to take me on a first date
i'm not
you know like i don't need him to pay
for me i just prefer guys that are like
that aren't going to fret over that
because i really wouldn't fret over that
like i've paid
my ex-boyfriend i would pay for like
small [ __ ] all the time she doesn't
believe in what she's saying she was
trying to find a way to justify
her desire of gender roles saying all
this [ __ ] about i put in all this
effort blah blah blah stop
you lying and it's okay i know you lying
right because you're doing this whole
like you know thing where you dance
around why you wanna
just say
i'm a woman that's what i deserve but
all this stuff about you dressing up boo
boo last i checked don't women dress up
for themselves
that's not check don't do them make them
do the makeup for them no
i'm gonna be honest no
dress up for guys themselves for you boo
boo don't they do the pedicure for
themselves lingerie two baboon right
don't they go to work and make sure
everyone else gets to see it damn shoes
is for youtube but did them [ __ ] pay
to see that no but i gotta pay to see
that don't bring that up don't
no
careful
careful cause what you said you it was
all for you
keep the same energy boo-boo
it was for you yep it's still for you
always
but
i have male friends who say they prefer
me like i was saying they prefer me with
my nails done my makeup done just
looking feminine and all that and like
don't go back to how you were before and
they're talking about how they want to
date me and stuff but then they're not
willing to pay for dates and all this
other stuff and it's like this costs
money you know you have a whole job for
that
if i'm paying you to look good and come
out there's a there's a word for that
that's a that's an escort service
i ain't mad at it
it's okay
oh [ __ ]
go go go on but we'll do your thing
escorts out there live your life you
want to be that live your life
but call yourself that that's that
escort mentality
that trophy wife thing
if i'm pain
shut the [ __ ] up
but my whole point is we didn't make
that a requirement you know what i'm
saying that's not a requirement from us
if you go to your job okay
and you put on your best makeup your
best nails your people are working like
damn you look good today all right you
came in nice and dressed extra extra we
appreciate that right does that mean
that they're going to give you a raise
because you put on your hair your makeup
and all that perfectly no
why because they didn't ask for that
they still hired you for the job
even though you came in looking great
so
at the end of the day ladies i support
y'all look as good as you
okay but then don't look at us and be
like
if you appreciate a lot of women always
talk about like subscribing to these
gender roles but you're not a lot of
y'all are not traditional women which is
perfectly fine but i just find it crazy
how y'all want to pick and choose when
you want to do these whole traditional
things
it's like that era is gone it's been
dead y'all are succeeding y'all killing
it y'all living your best lives pay up
all this talk about living
got that apron get back in that kitchen
start cooking home meals
why are y'all talking about
i like true traditional gender roles
y'all can't cook
y'all can't clean you can't cook cook
all right if i go through your crib your
bathroom chernobyl
let's be honest
so there's all this talk about like
subscribing to these roles that men
should pay but at the same time ladies
y'all move into the modern age so either
either you fully subscribe to the past
and you bout it about it but i'll be
trying to pick and choose all the time
the parts that you like because the
parts that you don't y'all don't want to
do and it happens to be the parts that
men like in traditional women
so that's my thing
that's pretty much my thoughts what do
you got i shut up man you did it
you threw my phone
you threw my phone too we quit come down
yeah bob i was bored i mean i understand
where they're coming from i just like
wouldn't want to be with the type of guy
that's going to fret that much over
a quick
like the first date
um second date third date sure we it
doesn't really matter just personal
preference
but yeah let me know what you guys think
in the comments don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell and i'll talk to you
guys next time